[Música]
todos sabemos lo que es arte artes
cualquier recreación humana de una
visión del mundo ya sea real o
imaginaria con usando recursos
lingüísticos sonoros o literarios con la
única finalidad de
dar sensaciones a los que la vean
recrear sensaciones y el big data
se define como el que el conjunto de
herramientas digitales que engloban una
gran cantidad un volumen muy grande de
datos a una gran velocidad y esos datos
son muy variados y vienen de distintas
fuentes y distintos formatos a mí
realmente la definición de big data que
más me gusta es aquella que me dice que
puedo que no puedo trabajar con los
datos desde mi ordenador
para mí programar siempre lo he
considerado como un arte empezabas con
una idea que era un lienzo en blanco la
creaban los bocetos que era la
estructura del programa las clases y
luego poco a poco vas añadiendo
dibujos trazos colores o líneas de
código hasta finalizar el cuadro o el
programa
pero cuál es la gran diferencia entre
crear un cuadro dibujar una obra de arte
y una aplicación informática pues que la
obra de arte perdura en el tiempo sin
embargo el programa con un simple clic
se borra a no ser que lo hayas
programado de una forma muy modular que
pueda ser convertido a otro programa lo
normal y lo que suele pasar es que se
aplicación se borre y se olvida y eso
realmente me frustró mucho
y llegué a pensar bueno si programar es
como arte porque no programar a arte y
todo empezó hace unos cinco años que vi
una charla de neil harbisson este es un
chico que nació con una enfermedad que
no le permitía o no le permite ver los
colores él ve todo en blanco y negro y
entonces él lo que hizo fue crearse una
antena que la lleva colocada encima de
la cabeza y esa antena lo único que hace
es ver los colores y transformarlos en
un sonido audible por el ser humano y él
se dejó implantar esa antena en la base
del cráneo de manera que con él a lo
largo del tiempo su cerebro que ha sido
capaz de interpretar esos sonidos y de
hecho él considera que tiene un sentido
más y puede
parece de broma pero él dice desde
entonces puedo vestirme acorde con los
colores porque él dice bueno pues suena
mejor suena peor me visto así yo no me
he visto así
también todo lo que ve lo interpretan
sonido el escucha las caras
de hecho él dice que le puede caer bien
una persona ver cómo suena su cara y eso
hace
que pueda pues bueno pues interpretar
los sonidos con los colores con la
música pero qué pasa si qué pasa si
hacemos lo contrario es decir él tenía
el algoritmo que transforma los sonidos
que transforman los colores en sonidos
pues cogió el mismo algoritmo y hizo lo
contrario y aquí se puede ver una
representación de cómo serían dos
canciones muy famosas la primera de
rehab de amy winehouse y la otra de para
lista de beethoven por supuesto se ve
una clara diferencia entre entre ellos
hace dos años llegó a mi mano un
artículo de la revista de yorokobu que
se titulaba cómo reducir una novela a
sus signos de puntuación en ella
describía el trabajo de nicolás rojo en
el que lo que hizo fue [ __ ] distintas
obras de la lectura literatura clásica
quitarle las letras y dejar solo los
signos de puntuación y con esos signos
de puntuación lo que hizo fue dibujarlas
en espiral de manera que podía
interpretar cuál era el estilo de cada
uno de los autores dependiendo de cómo
se veían sus cuadros investigando sobre
este señor me fascinó tanto el artículo
descubrí que había creado y tiene muchos
proyectos basados en el mismo sistema el
de convertir datos en algo totalmente
artístico esto es otro ejemplo del que
lo que hizo fue lo que su objetivo era
enseñar cómo es el tiempo en distintas
ciudades pero de una forma no la clásica
gráfica que uno normalmente ve que dice
oye pues
en invierno hace más frío que en verano
sí no
quería interpretar algo más quería
enseñar y entonces lo que hizo fue tomar
datos sin cinco mediciones diarias de 50
ciudades norteamericanas en las que
recogía la temperatura el viento y la
dirección y la dirección del viento y lo
representó de esta manera en la que cada
bolita se ve que la parte de arriba es
la temperatura máxima de esa toma de
medición desde ese día y la baja la
temperatura mínima
la
y la posición de cada bolita es la
dirección del viento y la distancia al
centro pues la intensidad del viento de
esta manera se puede ver claramente que
en nevada las temperaturas son muchísimo
más cálidas que en dakota del norte y
además el viento siempre sopla casi
siempre sopla en la misma dirección
resulta que este hombre fue inspirado
hacía dos años por stephanie pos a beck
stephanie en su trabajo de fin de máster
creó un proyecto que se llamaba writing
without words que lo que hizo fue
interpretar una novela en forma de árbol
en forma de flor en lo que cogía los
capítulos eran las ramas las sus ramas
los párrafos las frases las otras sus
ramas y las que terminaba en las hojitas
que eran las palabras y los distintos
colores representan las distintas
temáticas del libro pero qué pasa que
ella lo hacía todo a mano cogía con
rotuladores y bolígrafos extraía la
información que necesitaba la
clasificaba para poder realizar el
cuadro
resulta que esta chica inspiró a georgia
loop y yo ya lo vi es una italiana que
él había vio su trabajo y quiso trabajar
con stephanie dijo stephanie yo quiero
trabajar contigo y stephanie le dijo
desde eeuu no te conozco no sé si vales
te propongo un reto y el reto era que
durante todo un año
cada semana iban a decidir una temática
distinta se iban a poner de acuerdo y
cada una iba a recopilar los datos que
ellos querían interpretarlos de alguna
manera y al final de la semana lo tenían
que dibujar en una postal haciendo el
dibujito y enviarlo por correo postal a
la otra persona de esa manera cada una
podía ver cómo trabajaba la otra y este
proyecto salió también que escribieron
un libro que se llama díaz data en él se
puede ver cómo evolucionó su forma de
trabajar al principio escribían solo con
bolígrafo de color negro o azul pero
luego a medida que pasan las semanas se
ve que van añadiendo colores van
añadiendo nuestros recursos plásticos
pues me fascinó tanto el libro que
decidí hacer yo también el reto lance la
pregunta por internet y una amiga en la
península dijo yo también lo quiero
hacer contigo y empezamos a hacerlo a
ella le gusta mucho tomar el café y
entonces decidimos que la primera semana
sería la temática del café y estuve
siete días recopilando cada vez que me
tomaba el café anotaba oye qué tipo de
café me tomo en qué temperatura tiene
con quién estoy
me lo ha tomado muy rápido muy lento y
al final de la semana pues lo representé
en una forma una especie de pentagrama
donde cada nota representa pues el café
otra de las semanas que hicimos fue la
de las quejas esta no nos gustó nada
pero unos costos a la vez es bastante
pero lo que hice fue representar cada
día de la semana unas ramas que
evolucionan en espiral a la derecha si
son quejas dadas y a la izquierda quejas
recibidas y las hojitas pues representan
si son las quejas a mí a mis hijas del
servicio al trabajo etcétera y los
colores pues sobre sobre que se sobre
que iba la queja otra de las semanas que
hicimos que ésta ya me gustó un poquito
más fue sobre las gracias este recogí
muchísima información
y lo represente en forma de jardín de
flores en los que cada una de las de los
arbolitos representa un día de la semana
el tipo de hoja indica si son gracias
dadas o gracias recibidas los colores a
quien van dirigidas o de quien venían
las gracias y luego tiene algunos
detallitos como unas rayitas que
significa que fueron muchas gracias o
unos puntos
en los puntos
son los de nada de hecho lo que me llamó
la atención fue que nadie dice de nada
y bueno ahora ha pasado el tema
analógico había que pasarlo a digital
pues estamos recuerden que estamos
hablando de big data hábitat a digital
ya tengo los datos aunque son small no
son todavía byc ya tengo la forma de
extraer la información que quiero y
bueno ya trabajaba un poquito con una
visualización artística y entonces
estuve investigando a ver qué
herramienta podía usar herramienta
informática podía usar para hacer esta
representación pero no podía ser un
simple programa de dibujo por ordenador
porque el objetivo es tener datos en
tiempo real y que sean representados y
poder navegar por ellos en 3-d y di con
la herramienta day unity3d que es una
plataforma para la creación de
videojuegos muy potente que ya tiene
muchas herramientas de la física y lo
que hice fue pues la semana de gracias
de estas florecitas lo transformé en un
mundo en 3d donde cada jarrón es una
hora del día las flores son sí
dependiendo del tipo de gracias
y si la flor mira hacia ti es que te la
he dado la he recibido personalmente
pero si mira para otro lado pues que fue
por chat o por teléfono entonces pues
puedes navegar por este jardín y ver
cómo ha sido tu semana tu semana de
gracias y estos son en una prueba de
concepto la primera y ahora os quiero
enseñar la segunda que está todavía en
pañales que hace fatal porque se llama
se titula constelaciones y lo que he
hecho ha sido interpretar una novela que
se llama after dark de haruki murakami
en el que la visión es crear un mundo
estrellado
que las constelaciones son las frases
del libro las estrellas las palabras el
tamaño de la de las estrellas es el
tamaño de la palabra y su posición en el
espacio respecto a la otra estrella es
dependiendo si es una palabra un nombre
un adverbio un adjetivo un pronombre
etcétera más situados en el en el
espacio
para eso lo que tuve que hacer fue
primero extraer con un programa un
pequeño programita en python que
programe para extraer todo lo que no
fueran letras relevantes o sea los
signos de puntuación que la otra persona
acogió pues yo lo hice al revés cogí
solo las palabras y luego le pasé un
análisis sintáctico que me decía qué
tipo de palabra qué palabra es y eso
luego se lo doy al programa de unity 3d
que interpreta eso es texto es y crea
las estrellas entonces aquí hay
estrellas que nacen que se mueven pero
no se mueven y puedes poner el vídeo por
favor y entonces aquí les quiero enseñar
un poco cómo está el proyecto hoy en día
que es muy como lo dijo hasta les digo
está en pañales
pero se puede ver
no se puede un poco intuir cómo es la
creación de ese libro en un cielo
estrellado con el objetivo
de que si le añado sonido le añado los
colores dependiendo de los sentimientos
el sentimiento de la palabra y una nave
espacial que pueda volar por ese mundo
de estrellas es el objetivo que tengo
con él con el arte en big data muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]